tu l'a programmé pour qu'elle flirte
avec moi si c'était le cas ce serait de
la triche s'en serait pas qu'elle aime
c'est quoi ton type de fille noms de
villes et gagnent ben oui de fille c'est
quoi ton type de fille j'en attends ne
répond pas c'est la jolie blake disons
la corse est ton truc c'est notre
hypothèse de départ bien pourquoi c'est
ton truc parce que tu as fait une
analyse détaillée de toutes les races et
puis a croisé les données avec un
système de pondération
bien sûr que non tu est attiré par les
jolies black pointe
c'est le résultat d'une accumulation de
stimuli externes que tu n'as sûrement
même pas cap et quand tu les as kps que
tu l'a programmé pour je lui plaisent
oui ou non gelée programmé pour être
hétérosexuel ainsi que tu as été
programmé pour être hétérosexuel
personne ne m'a programmé pour un traité
en c'est un choix délibéré
je t'en prie bien sûr que tu as été
programmé par nature ou culture ou bien
les deux et pour être franc tu commence
à m'énerver parce que là c'est en
insécurité que j'entends c'est pas ton
intellect